hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar updates and the epidemiology
diagnosis and treatment of trichomonas
vaginalis and mycoplasma genitalium in
the u.s. i am michelle action of
laberd's and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots and
brought to you by Abbott molecular to
learn more about our sponsor please
visit www.dent.umich.edu/license
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
will report your problems by clicking on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen this
presentation is educational and best
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I now present today's speaker dr.
Cristina a buzzy associate professor of
medicine and epidemiology division of
infectious diseases at the University of
Alabama at Birmingham for a complete
biography on our speakers please visit
the file if you tap at the top of your
screen dr. Moseley you may now begin
your presentation
hello this is dr. christina love me
thank you so much for inviting me to
give this webinar today I'm going to
jump right in and get started
I have wonders
slide here at the beginning of the
webinar support for this program is
provided by Abbott and I am presenting
at the request of Abbott Apfel my
disclosures I'm currently funded by a
k23 award by NIAID which is a BB
pathogenesis study I also have funding
for an ro1 for a trichomonas vaginalis
treatment trial which we'll talk about
during this presentation in addition I'm
a consultant for loop and
pharmaceuticals and bio fire Diagnostics
I'm a speaker a member of the scientific
advisory board for Roche Diagnostics and
I'm also a speaker for Sofia and Becton
Dickinson
so the learning objectives for this
presentation today are to understand
populations at risk for trichomonas
vaginalis and mycoplasma genitalium I
want to briefly review some common
clinical presentations of these two
sexually transmitted infections in
addition to reviewing current diagnostic
methods including highly sensitive
nucleic acid amplification tests and
finally I'm going to end to talk about
treatment to give you some updates and
treatment regimens including the role of
antibiotic resistance so I'm going to
start out talking about the updates in
the epidemiology of trichomonas and
mycoplasma genitalium in the US and
internationally so last year some
updated in haynes data was published
regarding the epidemiology of
trichomonas in the United States and
this was published in Clinical
infectious disease Journal in 2018 this
data came from the 2013 to 2014 wave of
the in Haynes study and this was
actually the first time that they tested
both women and men for trichomonas in
this study and they did that by testing
urine specimens with the whole logic
gen-probe Optima trichomonas nucleic
acid amplification test and in the study
the women in the men were ages 18 of 59
years old and they found that the
national prevalence of trichomonas among
the u.s. women was 1.8%
and men was 0.5 percent and in this
study trichomonas was significantly
associated with female sex
african-american women the prevalence of
trichomonas in this group was eight
point nine percent so much higher than
women in general also having an older
age less than a high school education
being below the poverty level and having
greater than or equal to two sexual
partners in the past year were also
associated with having a positive test
for trichomonas
these prevalence estimates exceed
estimates of trichomonas burden and
other high income countries such as the
UK
we had an opportunity to also look at
the epidemiology of trichomonas
infection at our STI clinic here in
Birmingham Alabama where I work at the
University of Alabama at Birmingham and
this clinic actually started routinely
screening all women and men coming to
the clinic for trichomonas back in 2012
and this screening is done using the
holodeck optima trichomonas nucleic acid
application test the same one that was
used in the in Haines study that I just
mentioned and we had the opportunity to
look at the testing results for the
first year of this initiative at our
clinic and that we looked at over 6,000
patient records who got a trichomonas
test and we found the prevalence of
trichomonas at our clinic was 20%
overall so very high 27% prevalence and
women so about one out of every four
women coming to this clinic had
trichomonas and it was 9.8 percent in
men and you may ask why is the
prevalence even though it's high in men
why is it much lower in men compared to
women and there is some data suggesting
that trichomonas can't spontaneously
resolve in men so this may could account
for the lower prevalence however this
data is limited and further studies
needed on this topic here similar to
national data predictors of trichomonas
and women were older age an African
American race also co-infection with
gonorrhea was associated with
trichomonas and for men older age in men
and African American race were
significantly associated with the
positive trichomonas test and also
having greater than or equal to 5
white blood cells on a urethral Gram
stain was associate with trichomonas and
we know that trichomonas is a cause of
gonococcal urethritis in men
most importantly however in the study we
found that utilizing a nucleic acid
amplification test for trichomonas
diagnosis in women found 1/3 more
infections than if we just use the wet
mount alone in women and i'm going to
talk about trichomonas Diagnostics in a
few slides but this was a very important
finding in this study
right now trichomonas is not a
nationally reportable sexually
transmitted infection such as gonorrhea
chlamydia syphilis or HIV and I'll
mention also later that mycoplasma
genitalium is not a nationally
reportable sexually transmitted
infection either at this time back in
2013 the CDC published a paper in the
sexually transmitted disease Journal
explaining why at that time that
trichomonas was not nationally
reportable and they said that it only
met three out of seven necessary
criteria to be a nationally reportable
disease in this country it met the
criteria of frequency it is a very
common infection we do know that it met
the criteria of associated health
disparities which we do know that the
African American population is
significantly affected by this infection
meet the criteria of communicability we
do know that it is a sexually
transmitted infection however these
final four criteria the group that wrote
this paper said that meet these criteria
at that time which are severity a lot of
patients with trichomonas are
asymptomatic and they felt that the
adverse outcomes associated with
trichomonas are said to be uncommon
among mainly asymptomatic patients
however this has not been studied in
detail
they said that trichomonas associated
cost and burden to the healthcare system
is not well known and there's also
minimal data available in the cost
reduction from a screening program they
also said trichomonas does not meet the
criteria preventability there was no
data at the time and whether a national
control program would reduce trichomonas
prevalence especially they argued since
at the time chlamydia screening programs
were questionably effective and also
there is a lack of public interest that
at the time for trichomonas which could
reflect a lack of public knowledge that
the public doesn't know much about
trichomonas imagine
so as I mentioned this paper was written
now six years ago and it's going to be
interesting to see if there are updates
to this and what the updates are and if
this is going to influence whether or
not this infection becomes reportable in
the United States with regards to
national prevalence data on mycoplasma
genitalium
the first-ever population-based
prevalence estimate of this STD in the
United States was published in 2007 in
the American Journal of Public Health
and this was data that came from the ad
Health wave3 study of younger adults in
this country ages 18 to 27 years old
they found that the prevalence of Mg in
this group was one percent nationally
compared to gonorrhea was 0.4 percent
chlamydia was higher at 4.2 percent and
trichomonas was higher than mg but lower
than chlamydia at 2.3 percent almost all
of the mycoplasma genitalium infections
in this in this study were asymptomatic
similar to trichomonas the mycoplasma
genitalium prevalence was much higher
among african-americans in this study
and 11 times higher among respondents
living with a sexual partner and
interestingly they also found that
prevalence increased by 10 percent with
each additional vaginal sex partner
during the past year
also a study from the United Kingdom
that looked at the prevalence of
mycoplasma genitalium and British men
and women ages 16 to 44 so they included
an older population in this study this
is the Nats all three study this was
published a couple of years ago in 2015
and the participants were enrolled in
this study between 2010 to 2012 and they
did test urine specimens from
participants in this study and they
found the overall prevalence of
mycoplasma genitalium and men in this
study was 1.2 percent and in women was
1.3 percent when they stratified these
prevalences out by gender looking for
men in the women and by age they found
that the highest risk group of men in
this study were ages 25 to 35 and men in
that age group had a 2.1 percent
prevalence from mycoplasma genitalium
and in contrast younger women ages 16 to
19 had the most high prevalence of
mycoplasma genitalium at 2.4 percent in
this study risk factors for mycoplasma
genitalium in this study and others have
shown younger age at sexual debut again
african-american race greater number of
total and new sexual partners in the
past year having unsafe unprotected sex
reporting a history of other STDs as
I've listed on this slide and up to 39
to 50 percent of male or female sex
partners of infected patients also have
mycoplasma genitalium so the majority of
data on microcosmic genitalium
definitely suggest that it is a sexually
transmitted infection
now I'm going to go into some common
clinical presentations of both of these
trichomonas and mycoplasma genitalium
infections for the next few slides
the trichomonas vaginalis is a very
common cause of vaginal infection in
women you can see here in the left-sided
picture a very thin frothy looking
yellow whitish vaginal discharge which
is a very common clinical presentation
on the right picture you have the cervix
and you can see these punctate mucosal
hemorrhages that can be also seen for
trichomonas vaginalis infection and this
is classically called a strawberry
cervix in clinical practice we don't see
this very often however you can see it
and once you do see it it's a very
important physical exam finding pointing
to trichomonas vaginalis
I've also listed here some other common
clinical presentations and men and women
so in men on the left portion of the
slide it can cause urethritis I
mentioned earlier can be a cause of non
gonococcal urethritis and men I can
cause penile discharge dysuria however
again asymptomatic infection is very
common in both genders trichomonas can
cause an increased risk of HIV
acquisition in men it can also cause a
possible increased risk of prostate
cancer and it can also interfere with
sperm motility leading to infertility in
men who go untreated and women
trichomonas can cause a vaginitis the
cervicitis which I showed you with the
strawberry cervix it can also cause
endometritis and again in women similar
to men it can be asymptomatic infection
can be common trichomonas is associated
with increased risk of post
gynecological surgery infections as it's
untreated and it also is associated with
adverse birth outcomes and women
including premature rupture of the
membranes and low infant birth weights
and as I mentioned earlier increased
risk of HIV acquisition
clinical presentations of micro plasma
genitalium there is a strong association
with non gonococcal urethritis and men
in one study that I have listed here it
was the cause of n GU and men in
approximately 15 to 20 percent of cases
it's also a common cause of non
chlamydial non gonococcal urethritis and
approximately 20 to 25 percent of cases
and it's a cause of persistent
urethritis in 30 percent of cases with
regards to women it has been detected in
10 to 30 percent of women with
cervicitis which I have a picture listed
to the right showing a cervical
discharge coming out of the cervical off
on
and mycoplasma genitalium is also
associated with upper genital tract
infection and women a cause of PID in 2
to 20 percent of cases in one study but
less frequent cause of PID than
chlamydia it is also associated with
endometritis and tubal factor
infertility in women
there is an interesting study published
now back in 2007 looking at the
morphology of fallopian tubes after
mycoplasma genitalium infection in this
study it was an in vitro model of human
fallopian tube tissue where they have
the normal tissue in the far left
picture and then they infected this
tissue with either chlamydia or
mycoplasma genitalium
and they looked at outcomes analyzed by
scanning electron microscopy Orkin Sokol
microscopy in this study and as you can
see here others notable changes in the
morphology of the ciliated cells in the
fallopian tubes in chlamydial infection
and mycoplasma genitalium infection the
cilia are either swollen or have fallen
off of the epithelium in either of the
two infections as you can see however
though it is more severe loss of cilia
in chlamydia in the middle picture
compared to mycoplasma genitalium on the
right picture however it is definitely
abnormal in mycoplasma genitalium
it is important though to mention that
mycoplasma genitalium is not associated
with vaginal discharge and women and
testing women with vaginal discharge
alone for mycoplasma genitalium is not
currently recommended there was an
interesting meta-analysis of outcomes
for mycoplasma genitalium fected women
that was done a couple years ago now and
they looked at 21 studies in this
meta-analysis they did find that overall
mycoplasma genitalium
increased the risk of cervicitis and
women the risk of pelvic inflammatory
disease preterm birth and spontaneous
abortion and i have the odds ratios
listed the pool odds ratios listed on
the slide in red and in a sub analysis
that that they did in the study
accounting for STI co-infections in
addition to mycoplasma genitalium
infections all of the above associations
were stronger and remained statistically
significant
so now I'm going to talk
but about current CDC guidelines for
screening and diagnosis of trichomonas
and microcosmic Halley mycoplasma
genitalium in the US and I just want to
reiterate that this is based on the 2015
CDC STD treatment guidelines and for
everyone to note there are updated
guidelines coming out next year in 2020
so it will be very important to see how
these recommendations change or stay the
same at that time
the current CDC recommended screening
guidelines for mycoplasma and
trichomonas I have listed on this slide
here and I have it divided into certain
groups women and men women less than 25
years old or greater than 25 years old
hiv-positive women hiv-positive when men
and then in pregnancy
so for trichomonas for women and men it
screaming could be considered if you're
in a high prevalence setting or you're
at a high risk for infection and so for
example our STD clinic here in
Birmingham Alabama is a high risk high
prevalence setting so as I mentioned
previously our STD clinic routinely
implemented a screening program for
trichomonas back in 2012 so we are doing
that here but nationally people are not
routinely screening for trichomonas
unless they're in a high prevalence
setting or at high risk for infection
also important to note trichomonas
screening is not routinely recommended
at MSM at this time however for
hiv-positive women routine screening for
trichomonas is recommended at entry to
care and then annually thereafter and
also for pregnant women routine
screening for trichomonas is recommended
at the first prenatal visit for men it's
the same recommendation an hiv-positive
men as it is in HIV negative men which
is to consider screening if you're in a
high prevalence setting and in the 2015
CDC treatment guidelines there is no
recommendation at that time for
screening for mycoplasma genitalium in
either any of these groups
here are the current CDC recommended
testing sites and methods of diagnosis
for trichomonas and mycoplasma
genitalium and these are for symptomatic
patients
or in areas where trichomonas screening
is being done so for women and men for
both of these sexually transmitted
infections I have here listed in red
that nucleic acid amplification tests
are preferred methods of diagnosis even
back in 2015 it's important to note back
in 2015 however that we only had nucleic
acid amplification test for trichomonas
that were fda-approved in women at that
time so if you're going to do an enact
esthe in men
you would have to internally validate
one of the fda-approved trichomonas NAT
tests that are available in women and
I'll get into that in more detail
because I know it can get confusing with
regards to mycoplasma genitalium Nats
were the preferred testing mode out back
in 2015 however at that time there were
no FDA approved tests available we now
have two fda approved test for
mycoplasma genitalium which i will
mention in a few slides all of these
tests can be done on first catch urine
cervical or self collected vaginal
specimens for women or first catch urine
or your repro specimens for men it's
important to note that extra genital
testing of the throat or the rectum is
not recommended for either of these
infections
so this leads me into diagnosis of these
two infections and the ideal tests would
be a highly sensitive and specific test
such as a NAT test ideally that could be
performed at the point of care leading
to expedited treatment
with trichomonas and women obviously
majority of you will know about the wet
mount this is a rapid point-of-care test
that's been around for many years it's
important to know however you have to
get the vaginal secretion specimen from
the woman and this test must be
performed within 10 to 20 minutes after
specimen collection or the trichomonas
will lose their viability how the
sensitivity of this test is not very
good between 44 to 68 percent and the
best of hand
however the specificity is a hundred
percent so if you see trichomonas you
know for sure that the patient has it
another rapid point-of-care test for
trichomonas that's available is the
awesome test stick which is a rapid
antigen test for trichomonas this is a
point-of-care test to be performed only
on clinician collected vaginal
secretions it uses antibodies to detect
trichomonas protein antigens the test is
not validated in men so it should not be
used at this the sensitivity is 83% and
the specificity is 97% here you can get
results in about ten minutes from this
test the test however is more expensive
than doing a wet mount however you don't
have to have microscopy skills to do
this test but you do have to buy a
positive control kit which I have the
cost listed there on this slide
traditionally the gold-standard
trichomonas diagnostic test with culture
and now this is done in the in pouch
Culture Media which I have a picture
listed on this slide
I'm you have to inoculate a vaginal
secretion specimen into this pouch
within one hour of collection and the
pouch then has to be incubated
immediately at 37 degrees Celsius this
test is a moderately complex test by
CLIA it has to be read daily up to three
times over five to seven days to look
for a positive result and this obviously
causes a substantial delay between a
patient visit and getting a final result
and the census the
sensitivity can be a hundred percent
specificity is between forty four to
seventy-five percent for this it is
important to note that today we mainly
use culture when we're looking for
resistance because you can grow out the
organism in this media and subsequently
perform antimicrobial susceptibility
testing on the trichomonas I slit using
what's grown out in culture
occasionally trichomonas is seen on a
pap smear if you get a pap smear on a
woman conventional pap or liquid based
pap and the pathologist has read that it
has trichomonas on it definitely go
ahead and treat that patient if they
seem trichomonas the patient has it so I
would go ahead and treat that
ever now we have multiple nucleic acid
amplification tests available for
trichomonas diagnosis so we have lots of
tests coming through the pipeline as I
mentioned earlier the first one that
came out was the whole logic Optima
nucleic acid amplification test that was
fda-approved in women in 2011 so that's
the test that was used in the in Haines
study for trichomonas testing as well as
that's the test we currently use an AR
STD clinic this test has an excellent
sensitivity of 95 to 100% specificity of
98 to 100% the assay performance is
similar in asymptomatic and symptomatic
women however it does require central
lab processing and the results are not
available in real-time it's also not
fda-approved for men use and it has to
be internally validated by your
laboratory prior to being used for
patient care
the second trichomonas math test that
came out with the Becton Dickinson probe
tech test which was fda-approved again
in women only in 2014 this test is also
not FDA approved for use in men and has
to be internally validated again it
requires central lab processing and the
results are not available in real time
but it does have superior performance
versus weapon and its performance has
been found to be equivalent to the whole
logic Optima nat test
the next test which has come out as a
Cepheid gene expert trichomonas nucleic
acid application test which became FDA
approved and available in 2017 this is
the only FDA approved NAT test currently
for use in both women and men at the
point of care so this assay can provide
on-demand results within 65 minutes or
less with early termination for positive
results within 40 minutes so potentially
this test could give you your diagnosis
in real time at the clinic with a
smaller instrumentation if your patient
is willing to wait 40 to 65 minutes for
their test result and the system
specificity are very good for this test
as well similar to the abdomen
trichomonas nucleic acid amplification
test and this test can be used on male
first cat urine without having to be
internally validated
so now I'm going to shift gears a little
bit to fda-approved diagnostic tests
from mycoplasma genitalium and until
earlier this year we did not have an
fda-approved test in this country for mg
but now we have two the first is the
haulage ik Optima mycoplasma genitalium
test which was FDA approved in January
of 2019
this test is FDA approved for women and
men specimens which I have them all
listed here on this slide
including vaginal swabs in the cervical
swabs
female and male urine male urethral swab
and male penile me a dose swabs in
addition we also have the Roche Co vos
trichomonas and mycoplasma genitalium
test which is now FDA approved as a May
of 2019 and this test can also be used
in women and men on all these similar
specimens except they did not test it on
male urethra swabs in that study and as
you can see on this slide the test that
has the best sensitivity and specificity
for both Optima and Roche cobalt is a
vaginal swab specimen so right now I
showed you a slide a couple slides ago
that there's no current recommendations
for mycoplasma genitalium
screening in the United States there are
recommendations for diagnosis
potentially in symptomatic patients so
who should be tested moving forward now
that we have these two available tests
and I got the slide courtesy of one of
my colleagues at the University of
Washington Lisa manhart so who should be
tested moving forward I don't think that
there will be updated screening
recommendations for asymptomatic
patients we're not going to be screening
people routinely for mycoplasma
genitalia moving forward however we
there is going to be recommendation to
test symptomatic patients particularly
men who present when nan Gong cockle
urethritis and currently there's a
debate going on about whether or not we
should test all women which cervicitis
or pelvic inflammatory
up front from mycoplasma genitalium or
should we consider testing them for this
infection in persistent cases of
cervicitis or pelvic inflammatory
disease so I think it will be
interesting to see what the 2020 CDC STD
treatment guidelines are going to
recommend with regards to these two
situations currently right now there's
not a test of cure recommended for micro
plasma genitalium however it is
recommended to test and treat partners
of patients who do have mg
due to their high risk for also being
infected with mg similar to patients
testing and treating partners or
patients with other STDs
there is another test coming out by
Abbott on the illinit e-m-f TI si that's
coming through the pipeline right now
recently Abbott launched the new illinit
EMST is a for use with the elyda TM
system outside the US this test is an in
vitro pcr assay for use on the system
and it gives you qualitative detection
and differentiation of RNA from
chlamydia DNA from gonorrhea RNA from
trichomonas and RNA from mycoplasma
genitalium this is in one reaction or
one test to aid in the diagnosis of
these 4s t is in addition this test has
an exogenous internal control that's
included in the PCR reagent and is used
to confirm that no PCR inhibitors are
present in the sample this test reagent
also includes primers and probes that
amplify and detect an endogenous human
DNA sequence of cellular control a
sample of validity control for sample
adequacy extraction and amplification
efficiency both the cellular control in
the internal control are both used to
demonstrate assay validity it is
important to know that this assay in the
system RC e-mart but not yet FDA
approved in the u.s. finally I'm going
to talk about some updates in the
treatment of trichomonas and mycoplasma
genitalium and then we'll have some time
at the end of this presentation for
questions or comments from our listeners
the with regards to trichomonas part of
the 2015 CDC STD treatment guidelines
the preferred regimens are two drugs in
this one class of medication called five
nitro imidazoles the first drug is
metronidazole two grams orally in a
single dose or to knit as all two grams
orally in a single dose and then an
alternative regimen right now is
metronidazole 500 milligrams twice a day
orally for seven days it is important to
note that the seven day regimen of
metronidazole is currently the preferred
regimen for hiv-positive women right now
who have trichomonas and this is based
on the results of a randomized
controlled trial that was published back
in 2010 of hiv-positive women where the
seven-day metronidazole dose was found
to be more highly effective in
trichomonas infected hiv-positive women
compared to the two grams stat dose of
metronidazole I will mention the
differences between the two grams of
metro nas own the two grams of canada's
o on this slide is that metronidazole is
much cheaper than to knit Azul however
the half-life of tanam is all is a
little bit longer than metronidazole and
there are less GI gastrointestinal side
effects associated with tinidazole
however cost can always be an issue when
deciding between these two medications
so with regards to update and the
treatment of trichomonas our colleagues
at Tulane University Patty Kissinger and
her her research group recently did a
meta-analysis of prior treatment trials
of trichomonas and women that looked at
the two gram dose versus the seven-day
dose and they found that the pooled risk
ratio indicated higher treatment failure
for women receiving the single dose
metronidazole compared to the multi dose
metronidazole in this study
in addition we did a large trichomonas
treatment trial here in Birmingham at
UAB also in New Orleans at LSU and at
the University of Mississippi Medical
Center in Jackson Mississippi where we
directly compared the two grams fat dose
and metronidazole to the seven-day
metronidazole dose in HIV negative women
in this study went on from October of
2014 to 2017 and they were randomized in
a one-to-one fashion to either of these
treatment regimens and our primary
outcome of the study was looking at
trichomonas infection at tests of care
which is at 4 weeks after completion of
treatment we did get a nucleic acid
amplification test at that time and also
a culture in this study we enrolled 623
women across all three study sites who
were randomly assigned to the treatment
groups it's important to note that the
self-reported adherence was 99 percent
in the single dose group and also 96
percent so still high in the seven-day
dose group of metronidazole side-effects
were similar by group in the study with
the most cone being nausea vomiting and
headache and it's important to know in
this study that women receiving the
7-day metronidazole dose had a 45%
better treatment outcome than women who
got the 2 gram stat dose so similar to
the hiv-positive treatment trial that
was published back in 2010 this
treatment trial in HIV negative women
also found that the seven-day
metronidazole dose was more effective in
women
so because of this it's highly likely
that moving forward in new treatment
guidelines we're going to go to
metronidazole for the seven-day dose to
be the preferred regimen and all women
not just hiv-positive women and in men
it's likely going to be that the two
grams stat dose and metronidazole is
going to remain the recommended
treatment regimen because there's not
good RCT data looking at a head-to-head
comparison of these two doses yet in men
so there's pros and cons to making this
decision and updated guidelines pros for
making the seven-day regimen the
recommended regimen are the large
ongoing burden of trichomonas infection
in women in this country and the
superior effectiveness of the seven-day
dose the cons associated with this is
going to be issues with treatment
adherence now instead of getting a
directly observed therapy patients are
going to have to take medicine for seven
days which is going to require enhanced
counseling messages we also need data on
treatment adherence or trichomonas in
real world situations because the
adherence was good and our trial at 96%
however this was a clinical trial and
not the real world
and also if men are still going to be
treated with the two grams stat dose and
women now are going to be treated with
seven days there's going to be a
conflict in the timing of abstinence of
sex for a couple that could potentially
put a couple at risk for re-exposure
trichomonas so counseling messages are
going to need to be tailored for this
this is something important to know
that's coming through the pipeline
there's another five Natura metas all
that's currently being studied in this
country for the treatment of trichomonas
and this is called Signet azole this
medication was FDA approved back in 2016
for the treatment of women with BV in
the United States however it's not
currently FDA approved the treatment of
trichomonas there's currently a
randomized controlled trial of 12 sites
that's looking at signai dissol for
treatment of trichomonas in women so
it'll be interesting to see what the
results of that trial will be which
should be coming out in the next one to
two years it is important to mention
though that Signet as well has been used
for treatment of trichomonas in Europe
now for many years but the majority of
data and in Europe has been
observational data but acknowledge all
has been recently found to have better
in vitro activity against trichomonas
compared to my metronidazole and
trichomonas isolates from the US so this
is another emerging drug potentially
that we'll have available for
trichomonas in the future it is
important to note that sonatas all is a
one-time dose of 2 grams oral granules
so there potentially could be again
directly observed therapy for
trichomonas in women if this drug gets
to be FDA approved it is oral granules
which have to be dissolved in apple
sauce yogurt or pudding so that's a
little caveat associated with this
medication that you'll have to be aware
of if you use it in the future for a
treatment of trichomoniasis in women
finally the last thing I want to mention
about trichomonas is there is a little
bit of resistance to the 5 nitro
medieval drug class which is the main
class of drugs that we have to treat
this infection the largest study that
was ever published on that was now 7
years ago where they looked at over 500
trichomonas vaginalis isolates from six
clinics across the country
Birmingham our clinic here was one of
the study sites in this study and across
all of these isolates 538 to be exact
they found that low-level metronidazole
resistance was present in about 4.3
percent of isolates at that time there
was no moderate or high level resistance
to metronidazole and there was no
resistance to tune it azole thankfully
in the study although it was seven years
ago as I mentioned the authors of the
study stated that low level
metronidazole resistance is more common
than high level resistance and can be
overcome potentially with high dose oral
tune interval
there are CDC recommendations for dosing
in cases of suspected metronidazole drug
resistance so if you have a patient that
you've given a 2 gram stat dose to or
even the seven days a metronidazole that
is still infected with trichomonas and
you're excluding reinfection from an
untreated sexual partner if this happens
you definitely want to make sure that
they took the entire 500 milligrams
twice a day for seven days dose of
metronidazole if this does not work you
should consider performing
susceptibility testing on the
trichomonas
isolate which you would have to
inoculate vaginal secretions into one of
those in pouch cultures which I showed
you a picture of on a prior slide and
you would have to ship that to the CDC
for susceptibility testing on the
isolate which can take several weeks to
go through the shipping and testing
process in the meantime you can consider
giving high-dose metronidazole or
tendons all to grams orally daily for
five to seven days if that doesn't work
you can consider high dose oral tanana's
all at two to three grams daily and
divided doses in combination with
intravaginal to nizzle 500 milligrams
twice daily for 14 days this is a
relatively expensive regimen can get up
to $150 if patients don't have insurance
so that's something to consider another
alternative regimen would be high dose
oral to notice all plus intravaginal
parama Meissen cream which i have the
dose listed here nightly for 14 days it
is important to mention that the
intravaginal para Meissen cream has to
be compounded at a pharmacy so you can't
just get that at regular pharmacy you
have to get it made at a compounding
pharmacy in your area this can also be
pretty expensive there are other
regimens that have been tried down here
I have not recommended and they have not
had great success in case reports or
case series so they are not currently
recommended by the CDC for use in cases
of suspected metronidazole drug
resistance
so now finally I'm going to make a few
comments about the treatment of
mycoplasma genitalium so currently in
the 2015 CDC STD treatment guidelines
azithromycin one gram orally is
preferred over doxycycline 100
milligrams orally twice a day for seven
days
the doxycycline regimen has only been
found to have it 30 to 40 percent cure
of mycoplasma genitalium however over
the past several years the resistance of
mycoplasma genitalium to azithromycin is
emerging it's called these macrolide
resistance mutations Mr M's I have
listed on this slide and this has caused
resistance to is it there Meissen to go
up over the past several years the cure
rate for azithromycin pre 2009 was 89%
and now gone down to 67% after 2009 due
to these resistance mutations that are
emerging so currently if you look at the
CDC guidelines from 2015 they state if a
patient fails a one-gram is at their
Meissen dose you could consider giving
them a longer course of therapy which
totals out to be a 1 point 5 gram dose
if you give a 500 milligram dose
followed by 250 milligrams daily for 4
days however a recent study at 2017
found no difference in cure rates
between the 1 gram and the 1 point 5
gram total dose of azithromycin for
mycoplasma genitalium infection so I'm
not sure if this is going to this
recommendation is going to stay in the
guidelines moving forward up then
moxifloxacin 400 milligrams daily for 7
to 14 days has been successfully used in
treatment failures to azúcar Meissen
however the cure rates for moxie has
gone from a hundred percent down to 89
percent since 2010 so there is now also
some resistance to moxifloxacin that has
been occurring
with regards to PID treatment current
recommended PID treatments are based on
antibiotics that are not effective
against mycoplasma genitalium so if you
have someone that has PID that you're
worried they have persistent PID you're
worried that they haven't responded to
therapy you may want to consider
treatment for mycoplasma genitalium in
these cases with 14-day course of moxy
400 milligrams daily after you've
treated them with a regular recommended
PID rep antibiotic treatment regimen
there is going to be some talk about
treating mycoplasma genitalium in the
absence of testing so if you're unable
to do a nucleic acid amplification test
on your patient and the two special
situations here are going to be
persistent or recurrent ngu or
cervicitis or persistent or recurrent
pelvic inflammatory disease and right
now there's some talk about giving a
seven day course of dicey cycling
followed by moxie 400 milligrams daily
for seven seven days for persistent or
recurrent ng or cervicitis in the
absence of testing the thought of giving
the the first course of doxy is to treat
perhaps chlamydial infection that may be
present also to perhaps decrease the
bacterial load of the mycoplasma
genitalium which could then subsequently
be killed by moxifloxacin given after
the initial course of doxycycline and
the same thought process goes into
persistent or recurrent PID however the
the course of daxing moxy here should be
for 14 days not seven days
my last slide that I wanted to mention
there is a very interesting study that
was just published a couple of months
ago out of the Australian group looking
at outcomes of resistance guided
sequential treatment of mycoplasma
genitalium so the sequential treatment
is is something that I mentioned in the
slide before which is kind of coming
down through the pipeline and in light
of this is the perm ice and resistance
getting worse and moxifloxacin
resistance now coming on so here in this
study they actually tested patients for
mg and macrolide resistance mutations by
a PCR test they have available in
Australia for patients that had mg they
initially gave them the seven-day doc C
course to decrease the bacterial load
and then after doxy their patients who
did not have a macrolide resistance
mutations they got 2.5 grams of
azithromycin overall and then the micro
allied resistance mutation positive
patients instead received Siddha flock
lesson which is a novel
fourth-generation fluoroquinolone
antibiotic and it's interesting to note
that in their study almost two thirds of
their study population actually did have
a micro plasma resistance mutation so a
larger proportion gots that ofloxacin in
the study then the to Gramma's it
reminds and dose
however both of the arms with the
sequential therapy regimen they did find
microbiologic care was pretty good
almost 95% in the macrolide resistance
mutation negative infection versus 92%
in the macrolide resistance mutation
positive arm and this this difference is
not statistically significant and they
found that selection of macrolide
resistance only occurred in 2.6 percent
of the macrolide resistance mutation
negative infections that got the 2 point
5 gram dose of azithromycin so I just
mentioned this study because just to
call to your attention the fact that
sequential therapy is on the table
perhaps for treatment of mycoplasma
genitalium moving forward so you may be
hearing or reading more about this as
additional studies progress in this
field so that's all I have today about
my updates for trichomonas and
mycoplasma genitalium I'm not going to
take questions and comments and I have
my email listed on this slide
see Mosley at UAB MC edu if you want to
just email me if you have a question or
a patient scenario that you'd like to
discuss I'd be more than happy to take
your questions thank you so much again
to Abbott today for letting me do this
webinar
Thank You dr. Maas me for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
alright let's get started our first
question is in your opinion what more is
needed from the FBI FBI prevention
community public health labs and
diagnostic manufacturers to strengthen
the position to make mycoplasma
genitalium and trichomonas vaginalis
reportable to the CDC thanks so much
Michelle and thanks to everyone for
listening to this webinar I think this
is a great question to start out with I
think one of the most important things
that we need to know more about is the
natural history of infection with both
trichomonas vaginalis and mycoplasma
genitalium
with regards to the CDC making them
reportable diseases I think both of
these infections are known to cause to
be asymptomatic and a number of patients
and right now it's not clear if having
that infection but being asymptomatic
has any adverse outcomes for patients we
do know that some patients are
symptomatic clearly patients with
vaginitis or with trichomonas or
cervicitis pelvic inflammatory disease
etc from microcosmic genitalium we do
know about those consequences but I
think we need more data on asymptomatic
infections and one other thing about
making it a reportable disease that have
to meet all all seven of those criteria
that I mentioned in one of my slides and
right now trichomonas in the last paper
that was written about it only meets
three out of those seven criteria and
mycoplasma genitalium right now does
only meets a few of those criteria as
well so I think we need a lot more data
on some of these other aspects
great thank you do you accept self
collected vaginal swabs for testing yeah
so self collected vaginal swabs are
great patients like to do that and you
may not have to do a pelvic exam or
physical exam in those situations I
think depending on what tests you're
going to have a patient self collect a
vaginal swab I would just make sure that
it's approved for that particular test
for example in one of my slides I
mentioned the Becton Dickinson probe
tech essay for trichomonas vaginalis
nucleic acid amplification test that is
approved for self collected vaginal
swabs and women and so for a lot of
these other tests that I've talked about
today I would just check the package
insert or look online really quick just
to make sure that you can have the
patients collect a swab for that
particular test so I think it would vary
depending on the test
okay great thank you what is the best
diagnostic approach in settings where
point-of-care tests are not available
yeah I think in settings where
point-of-care tests are not available I
think you would just collect a vaginal
swab or in men a urine sample and you
would basically have to send them out to
a reference laboratory to get a nucleic
acid amplification test those tests are
the most sensitive and specific for many
of these sti's and for trichomonas and
mycoplasma genitalium that's what I
would do if I did not have a
point-of-care diagnostic test available
to me
you
okay now in your opinion what are the
main points that should be investigated
about tea vaginalis and M genitalium to
move forward in the knowledge of these
FDI yeah I think one is what I mentioned
a little while ago I think we need to
better understand the natural history of
these infections and what exactly is
asymptomatic infection doing and the
other thing that I think is really
important is what is the cost to the
healthcare system in the United States
that these infections are causing so
cost data is definitely needed in this
country I think those are two very
important things to look for in future
studies
okay we have a user that asks would you
mind repeating when the results of the
clinical study will be published all the
one abouts ignite azole for trichomonas
correct yes yes so that study started
enrolling in the United States in May of
2019 it's currently ongoing
so it's actively enrolling I think they
have about 12 study sites and they need
to enroll about a hundred and fifty
patients across all the state all these
sites in that study and I think that
they've gotten about sixty patients so
far so I foresee that that trial is
going to be going on you know for the
rest of 2019 and into 2020
probably with results available perhaps
at the end of 2020 or early 2021 so
there's still a little bit more time
that's going to take to finish that
study great thank you
all right what is the value of the
currently approved ffs dan80 T V and M G
tests in the view of the emerging
antibiotic resistance
yeah so that's an excellent question so
basically with trichomonas none of the
currently approved mat tests detect
resistance so that's one caveat if you
want to look for resistance you have to
get a trichomonas culture and that's
where they do the antibiotic
susceptibility testing on that and so
you would either have to send your
isolate to the CDC or if you're at an
institution that does metronidazole
susceptibility testing on trichomonas
cultures you could do it at your own
institution but right now we don't have
any mat test for trichomonas that are
going to detect resistance with regards
to mycoplasma genitalium the two NAT
test that I talked about right now that
are currently available also do not
detect resistance mutations however
there are NAT tests and development that
are coming down the pipeline that do and
one that I recently found out about just
yesterday is a mat test from speedix
that will detect macrolide resistance
mutations so that's something to be
looking for in the future but not
currently available now
thank you is the prevalence of TV higher
and older age group females
yes so
traditionally trichomonas has been more
commonly associated in older women and
this is in contrast to other STDs like
chlamydia which are seen in younger age
groups so women usually less than 25
years old we see the highest rates of
Chlamydia
but for trichomonas it's an older age
group women and you may ask well why is
this different and it may because it may
be because trichomonas right now we're
not routinely screening everywhere
across the country for it and infections
can be asymptomatic so women could have
it for multiple years and be
asymptomatic and not be screened for it
and not know that they have it and then
later on down the pipeline when they
become older they may develop symptoms
later on and then may be tested for it
and found to have it and so i think i
think it's it's a reflection of not
routinely screening for it in the
country
great thank you it looks like we have
time for one last question the largest
demographic of patients at one of my
sites are predominantly Medicaid insured
given that mg is not yet recommended for
routine testing do you know anything
about reimbursement or Medicaid for this
test
yes I do not know about that currently
these mycoplasma genitalium test just
became available a couple of months ago
however I can assure you that the CDC is
going to take a stance on when these
tests should be used and that's going to
come out in the 2020 guidelines which
are expected in the spring of next year
and hopefully once they take a firm
stand on when to use these tests then
ensure you know insurance companies will
be able to reimburse in those situations
so be on the lookout for those
guidelines coming out you know hopefully
within the next six months
great thank you again dr. mesme for your
time today in your important research
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Abbott molecular
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their questions
any questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the on
demand period will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information be
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
laboratory you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye